you go farther back in the book okay
further back why did you guys [ __ ]
bookmark that
we didn't we didn't bookmark it we
didn't name bookmarked oh it came
bookmark
i didn't read any of these that's not my
journal to read
okay yeah you should at another level
april
april 19 1995. these stand up gigs are
bringing me down
i hit a new low tonight i stripped naked
stuff [ __ ] up my nose
balanced an ashtray on my head and stuck
a microphone up my ass just to get a
laugh
what the [ __ ] does paying your dues mean
anyway
who the [ __ ] do i have to pay and why i
hate this
i can't do it anymore i've really only
been doing it since mid-january and yet
i'm sick and tired of it all
i was doing so well about a couple of
weeks ago i did two
smoking smoking sets
two smoking sets at the comedy store and
the last two have been
shitty [ __ ] i need more material and i
need to move
to be more consistent will i ever get
good who knows
at least i'm trying wow that's actually
some good insight
do you remember that no you don't i
don't believe i i never use smoking
you smoke in here and then you want to
just read all the pages then why do you
have to keep skip
so that's good yeah yeah yeah wow so
there was that's almost the start of
when you started doing more of the crazy
stuff then
no i i started that way oh yeah
okay here we go this is a love one oh
this is going to break my heart
why can't you be this sweet again
[Laughter]
i wish he would write about me this way
he cleaned up cans today i think that's
a that's a new love letter
okay march 15 1996.
i love anna i love her enough to accept
the fact that we are just
good friends oh dude you're a poet bro
[ __ ] you i love it oh sweetie
we spent the night driving around trying
to find juvenile hall
for one of the kids that anna tutors
after anna gave me a hug
that hug was intimate and it felt
comfortable i realized at that moment
that she isn't like the others
that's more the reason that i'm lucky to
be her friend
dude that's good i'm 24 old enough to
know
that sex romance and all the other
pressures that my peers throw at me
are not that important i'm set free
who are you wow
why is that so do you feel that way no
i don't know why i'm crying i get it
i'm crying a little bit i think i don't
believe any
like all of these stories that you say
you are about being
like this dirt bag this this and that i
know you like in your heart this is who
you are
when you were 24 and you were this
sensitive loving
tender man who would never who would
just look at a girl and be like okay
i'll take the friendship
yeah that [ __ ] made me cry broke me babe
keep breathing okay okay
i guess it's a different tone what
happened after that i'm set free
after that i'm set free there's a little
tagline underneath keep going
there's a tag underneath it says when
she said we are close personal friends i
knew it was over
march 24th 1996. i've changed my
attitude
i can't live my life by what others
think of me i'm gonna concentrate on
what i need to do
there you go okay may 9 1996 seven years
of sobriety
and growing if i died tomorrow i will
have no regrets
damn bro wow
february february 2nd 1997 wow a whole
year after
you didn't write for a year i am a paid
regular at the hollywood comedy store
and i just got back from vegas opening
for polly's show that's crazy that's in
that book
yeah okay here's your five year plan
here i have a manager worthy patterson
who happens to manage
who happens to manage carlos mencia lots
of things have happened in the last
couple months but i need to stay focused
i can
hardly care if i do good or bad on stage
because i know i'm funny
and i mean i'm becoming a lot more
original i'm still hooked on anna
crackers oh you're after i'm still
hooked on anna and it is scaring me
i hope that i meet somebody else yeah
even if i'm able to
even if i'm able to date anna
it's still an impossible situation since
i'm so focused on my career now as a
comic
i'll give this comedy comedy thing my
best for the next five years
this is my five-year plan number one tv
show
number two movies number three hbo
special
overall plan enough money number two a
wife
number three kids just got half of them
wow march 23rd
1998. this is two years after
oh no a whole year after today i'm
auditioning for a movie that
has nicolas cage in it who is that what
movie is that
i've been in the main room six times
since i've moved to la i've done two
more tv shows
i just need to focus on my act and stay
humble finances are low
and i don't think i can maintain this
kind of living for much longer
so he's thinking about it
wow you got cocky real quick yeah go
ahead i wanna
well fast forward my true self comes out
is this the turn i want to see the turn
i want to see the turn into the reel
2002 is when you turn
yeah we're here into a hollywood vampire
what are you doing here oh man this is
this is four years later um april 28
2002 i make seven thousand dollars a
week and i have forty thousand dollars
in
investments that's all you wrote for
that thing
what happened to the i'm in love with
anna anna
it's kind of hard this is my financial
portfolio
it gets worse i think after that and it
gets worse what was the switch
what the [ __ ] happened to you that's
when that's when i that's when i changed
that's when you became probably
incorrigible to other people i was
really bad then
i was really bad then but um let's see
if you get better at all oh
oh let me tell you something four years
five years have passed
yeah but you're still hooked on anna
really yeah
let me see let me see it let me is this
2002 april 28th
last night i did my first tonight show
appearance jay leno talked to me in my
dressing room for 20 minutes
i didn't hear a word he said because i'm
like [ __ ] jay leno is talking to me
he's got a huge chin currently i'm on a
sketch show
on fox called mad tv and i hate it but
i'm
true but i i make more money than i have
ever had and the [ __ ] potential is out
there
it's out there
[Laughter]
i'm oh god i'm seeing a hot model type
hey i'm going to keep it blank
why and she costs a lot of money why
what
did you hire her i might have hired
somebody let me see the name
let me see the name or maybe she just
caught like clothes and stuff like that
oh yeah yeah
she's crazy wait but she she wanted you
to buy a lot of things for her yeah yeah
i'm seeing a hot model type and she
costs a lot of money
i have a great agency behind me gersh
and my manager
is the best abby oh
i'm pretty [ __ ] happy side note
anna's married and she's pregnant
oh you've been following her but i'm
truly happy for her
things happen when they happen and
nothing matters but god
so shut the [ __ ] up bobby because you're
driving yourself crazy
dude i feel like i shouldn't be sitting
here in the and i should be here instead
why wow you've i i feel like i want to
see
how this love story could have panned
out it never would appear
it would never pan out that was the last
thing you wrote yep
wow you held a candle for anna for a
really long time and my heart breaks for
this this the little boy that that
couldn't
ever feel you know the love in return